Whether they broke things off quickly or they're
still happily married with five kids, these
fictional relatives ended up in very real
relationships.
Anna Kendrick and Bill Hader play the adult
children of Santa Claus who save Christmas
in the 2019 Disney+ holiday movie "Noelle."
This stint as festive movie siblings led to
a romantic relationship off the screen.
A source told Us Weekly —
"Bill and Anna clicked right away.
They dig each other's sense of humor."
The source made sure to clarify that nothing
happened between the two until they were both
single at the same time.
Hader got a divorce from his wife Maggie Carey
in 2018 — and before dating Kendrick, he
had a relationship with Rachel Bilson, his
co-star in "The To Do List."
In January 2022, sources revealed that Kendrick
and Hader were dating and had been keeping
their relationship under wraps for under a
year.
According to Cosmopolitan's math, Kendrick
and Hader got together sometime between July
2020 and December 2020.
With speculation about the status of their
relationship rife, a source told ET —
"Bill and Anna are in love and very happy
in their relationship, and enjoying their
time together."
Hader didn't respond to the comments, choosing
to keep their relationship private for the
sake of his daughters.
Unfortunately, things just didn't last for
these on-screen sibs, with ET reporting that
the two broke up in June 2022.
It's unlikely that we'll see Kendrick appear
in any of Hader's future projects.
"Lots of guest stars here tonight — could
we ever see Anna Kendrick as a guest star?"
"Oh…
no."
"No way?" [nervous laughter]
"No way?"
After seven years on "Gilmore Girls," Lauren
Graham took a small break from TV before taking
on the role of another single mom in the comedy-drama
"Parenthood."
Graham's Sarah Braverman is the mom to Mae
Whitman's Amber and Miles Heizer's Drew.
She also shares the screen with "9-1-1" star
Peter Krause, who plays her brother, Adam.
The two play siblings in the series, but it
didn't stop them from falling in love in real life.
Graham has her "Gilmore Girls" TV mom, Kelly
Bishop, to thank for encouraging her to date Krause.
The pair obviously had a natural chemistry,
but Graham has said that they were both hesitant
to act on it because of past unsuccessful
relationships they'd had with co-stars.
After having worked together for a while on
"Parenthood” though, they decided to take
the plunge.
Ultimately, Graham felt that working in the
same industry actually ended up being of benefit.
The actor told People —
"It's hard to explain to people when you have
a fancy job like being an actor what is challenging
about it.
So we just kind of have that shorthand, a
shared language, which is helpful."
Their differences eventually caught up with
them, and they ended up separating after more
than a decade together.
During their relationship, Graham took on
an important step-motherly role in the life
of Krause's son Roman — something she plans
to continue even after their 2021 break-up.
David Tennant has played some impressive roles
throughout his career, including Barty Crouch
Jr. in "Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire,"
Kilgrave in "Jessica Jones," and Crowley in
"Good Omens."
Of course, his most iconic role will always
be that of the tenth Doctor in the BBC's "Doctor Who."
It was the role that kept on giving — it
introduced him to Georgia Moffett, the woman
who would eventually become Mrs. Georgia Tennant.
There's just one thing, though…
"She's… well… she's my daughter."
"Hello, Dad."
The fictional relation didn't seem to bother
them: the pair started dating in 2008, and
they married at the end of 2011.
David Tennant admitted to The Independent
—
"Because Doctor Who had run through my life
like a stick of rock, to end up marrying the
daughter of one of the doctors, it all felt
a bit stupid — there were a lot of things
against it."
Moffett, who is the real-life daughter of
fifth Doctor actor Peter Davison, didn't give
up on their connection — and it all worked
out in the end.
Tennant continued —
"You reach a point of your life when you're
looking for someone and it's sort of chance
which version of that perfect partner ambles
along."
As of 2023, the actors are still happily married
and share five kids together, including "House
of the Dragon's" Ty Tennant.
Milo Ventimiglia starred in "Heroes" from
2006 to 2010 as Peter Petrelli, who turns
out to be the uncle of Hayden Panettiere's
Claire Bennet.
Their familial status in the series didn't
stop their off-screen connection, though;
the pair dated from 2007 to 2009 — just
a year after Ventimiglia had separated from Alexis Bledel.
Panettiere had also recently ended her two-year
relationship with "Laguna Beach" star Stephen Colletti.
A family friend confirmed their relationship
in 2007, telling People —
"Hayden's mom adores Milo.
She thinks he's so cute.
She tells her friends that he's her boyfriend.
She's very proud."
To some fans, however, the age gap in their
relationship was controversial.
Panettiere was just 18 when they began dating,
while Ventimiglia was 29.
At the time, Ventimiglia didn't want to fan
the media flames of their relationship, denying
anything romantic and claiming they were just
good friends.
Ventimiglia and Panettiere ended up staying
together for almost two years.
Although they did not publicly comment on
their split, another source told People —
"They lead different lifestyles.
He's 31, she's 19.
She still has growing up to do and he's very
low-key."
According to the outlet, the pair remained
cordial, and they continued to work on "Heroes"
together until the show ended.
Barry Williams and Maureen McCormick are more
often recognized as Greg and Marcia — two
of the siblings from "The Brady Bunch," which
aired from 1969 to 1974.
Tales of their off-screen relationship are
infamous, and the pair have both been open
about their time together over the years.
In fact, McCormick and Williams enjoyed their
first kiss together while shooting the first
episode of Season 4 in Hawaii, as the actors
revealed during an appearance on "Watch What
Happens Live!"
"Scale of one to ten."
"Ten.
Wow!"
McCormick revealed in her book, "Here's the
Story: Surviving Marcia Brady and Finding
My True Voice" —
"There was so much electricity between us
that I felt the hair on my arms stand up every
time we got close to each other...
I thought about Barry even when I had other
scenes with other guys.
I used to ask myself how I could ever look
in eyes other than his liquid blues and feel
such love."
However, their intense attraction did make
it difficult when filming a scene later in
Season 4 in which the teen actors had to sit
on the bed together.
McCormick admitted —
"We couldn't keep our hands off each other."
Despite their strong feelings, the on-off
relationship between these on-screen siblings
didn't work.
It eventually fizzled out, with McCormick
saying that timing got in their way.
There are no hard feelings, though: the former
couple are still close friends decades after
their split.
Emily VanCamp and Chris Pratt are both known
for starring in the MCU, with VanCamp playing
SHIELD agent Sharon Carter and Pratt traversing
the galaxy as Star-Lord.
But over a decade before their superhero adventures,
the actors worked together on the show "Everwood"
playing siblings Amy and Bright Abbott — and
they fell in love on set.
In 2006, Pratt admitted that he felt a little
weirded out starting a romantic relationship
with his on-screen sister — as did fans.
He told TV Guide —
"Yeah, we've pretty much gotten used to the
response of, 'Eww, that's weird.'
The people who know us are happy, and probably
expected it to happen eventually.
But yeah, every once in a while we get that
one person that's like, 'That's really creepy.
You just kissed your sister.'"
VanCamp and Pratt ultimately ignored the haters
and let their love blossom, dating from 2004
to 2007 before going their separate ways.
As of 2023, VanCamp is happily married to
her "Revenge" co-star Josh Bowman, with whom
she shares a daughter.
Meanwhile, Pratt also has three kids: a son
with his ex, Anna Faris, and two daughters
with his wife, Katherine Schwarzenegger.
Before she married Josh Bowman but after dating
Chris Pratt, Emily VanCamp dated another of
her on-screen siblings: her "Brothers and
Sisters" co-star, Dave Annable.
Before Annable met his now-wife Odette during
the show's fifth season, the pair dated for
over a year.
When the show kicks off, VanCamp's character
Rebecca is shown to be the half-sister of
Annable's character Justin, but this storyline
was later changed by the series creator, Greg Berlanti.
Berlanti told Entertainment Weekly —
"I looked like an idiot ... Here were two
young people who didn't grow up with each
other, didn't know each other, but they had
this electricity.
There was nothing I could do."
In the second season of "Brothers & Sisters,"
Rebecca discovers she's not a member of the
Walker clan after all, which leaves her and
Justin free to date.
The shocking twist was a welcome storyline
for the real-life couple: VanCamp told EW —
"I'm all for breaking boundaries, but we didn't
need to get into incest.
I draw the line at that."
Regardless, it didn't last: VanCamp and Annable
called it quits in 2008 but continued working
together until she departed the series in
2010.
In 2006, Jennifer Carpenter and Michael C.
Hall met on the set of "Dexter."
Hall played the titular Dexter Morgan, while
Carpenter played his sister, Debra.
At some point between their first meeting
and 2008, the pair got together — and their
romance only intensified, culminating with
a marriage on New Year's Eve that year.
Around that time, Carpenter told On Demand
Entertainment —
"We had a great base for our relationship.
We see each other on a day-to-day basis and
you know, I know him and he knows me."
The fact that they played siblings didn't
seem to get in the way or make things weird, either.
Things got serious in 2009 when Hall was diagnosed
with Hodgkin's Lymphoma, and Carpenter supported
him until he reached remission.
The pair seemed stronger than ever — but
sadly, it simply wasn't meant to be.
They divorced in 2011, but continued to play
siblings on the show until it ended in 2013
— and they reunited for the limited series
sequel, "Dexter: New Blood."
Carpenter told Today that they will always
have a close friendship, saying —
"Just because the marriage ended doesn't mean
the love isn't still there."
Katherine Heigl goes by many names.
To a lot of her fans, she's the queen of romantic
comedies from the 2000s, while others will
always see her as Izzie Stevens from "Grey's
Anatomy."
Before all of that, though, she was Isabel
Evans in the sci-fi drama "Roswell" from 1999
to 2002, alongside Shiri Appleby, Brendan
Fehr, and Jason Behr.
Behr played her on-screen adopted brother,
Max.
Isabel and Max were close — but not as close
as Heigl and Behr, who dated off-screen for
most of the show's run.
Although they largely kept their relationship
out of the public eye during that time, there
was enough attention on the actors to spark
romance rumors before they split in 2002.
Behr soon moved on from their relationship
after meeting fellow actor KaDee Strickland
on the set of "The Grudge" in 2004.
They tied the knot in 2006 and welcomed a
son in 2020.
Heigl also got engaged in 2006, marrying musician
Josh Kelley the following year.
They have three children.
Before she became a household name for starring
opposite Patrick Swayze in "Dirty Dancing,"
Jennifer Grey played Jeannie Bueller in the
beloved '80s teen comedy "Ferris Bueller's
Day Off" alongside Matthew Broderick.
As Ferris and Jeannie, Broderick and Grey
portray a tumultuous sibling relationship
— but their relationship off-screen was
much less strained.
Grey admitted in her memoir, "Out of the Corner"
—
"I was as surprised as anyone when our relationship
morphed from on-screen sibling rivalry to
off-screen illicit romance."
The couple did everything they could to keep
their romance under wraps, stealing away moments
together on set.
They were so enamored with each other that
they became engaged before filming had even ended.
"Heh… oh, kids!"
Grey later revealed that her career-defining
role in "Dirty Dancing" took its toll on their
relationship, admitting that she felt unsupported
by Broderick.
At this point, the couple was still hiding
their relationship — but the truth came
tumbling out when they were involved in a
serious car crash in Northern Ireland in 1987.
This signaled the beginning of the end for
the couple, who called it quits the following
year without tying the knot.
Broderick eventually went on to marry "Sex
and the City" star Sarah Jessica Parker, while
Grey rebounded by getting engaged to Johnny
Depp.
They didn't end up together in the end, though,
as Grey shared 19 years of marriage with Marvel
star Clark Gregg before announcing their separation
in 2020.